[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin in allen einen schönen guten
Abend katja hat später wieder das
sportliche für Sie im Blick sehr gern
guten Abend wir blicken jetzt gemeinsam
auf die Themen
jetzt ist es offiziell der 80-Jährige
Joe Biden will noch einmal Präsident der
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika werden
das Zeitfenster schließt sich die
Bundeswehr beendet am Abend ihre
evakuierungsflüge aus dem Sudan
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Sänger Schauspieler Kämpfer gegen
Rassismus harry Belafonte stirbt im
Alter von 96 Jahren
[Musik]
schon jetzt ist Joe Biden ältester
US-Präsident der Geschichte und könnte
es bleiben der 80-Jährige kündigte heute
seine Kandidatur für eine zweite
Amtszeit an kritiker fürchten dass er
den Strapazen des Jobs nicht mehr
standhält im Rennen ums Weiße Haus
könnte es jetzt wieder auf ein Duell
beiden gegen Trump hinauslaufen beide
Lager bringen sich in Stellung Benjamin
Daniel berichtet
kein großer Auftritt keine Inszenierung
lediglich dieses Video postet das Weiße
Haus um Punkt 6 Uhr Ortszeit Washington
Joe Biden wirft für die
Präsidentschaftswahl 2024 seinen Hut
erneut in den Ring er teilt hart aus
gegen jene die Demokratie und Freiheiten
oder das Recht auf Abtreibung
einschränken wollen
als ich vor vier Jahren angetreten bin
habe ich gesagt wir kämpfen um die Seele
Amerikas und das tun wir noch immer wir
müssen uns der Frage stellen ob wir in
den kommenden Jahren mehr Freiheit und
Rechte oder weniger haben wollen
mit 80 Jahren ist er bereits jetzt der
älteste US-Präsident aller Zeiten viele
sehen das als Problem auch unter den
Demokraten dennoch muss der Amtsinhaber
wohl nicht mit ernsthafter Konkurrenz
aus den eigenen Reihen rechnen auch
seine Stellvertreterin Kamera Harris die
viele zu Beginn ihrer Amtszeit als
mögliche Kandidatin gesehen hatten soll
auf ihrem jetzigen Posten bleiben und so
kann sich Joe Biden auf die
republikanische Konkurrenz konzentrieren
Donald Trump postete heute als Reaktion
sein eigenes Video in dem er Joe Biden
als den schlechtesten Präsidenten aller
Zeiten beschreibt wir werden Joe beiden
2024 besiegen wir werden unsere
Wirtschaft retten die Inflation
zerschlagen die Invasion an unserer
Südgrenze stoppen wir werden die würde
unserer Nation wiederherstellen und wir
werden den Dritten Weltkrieg verhindern
beobachter rechnen damit das auch
Floridas republikanischer Gouverneur
rondes früher oder später ins Rennen
einsteigen wird und so ist spätestens ab
heute klar der Wahlkampf in Amerika für
2024 hat begonnen
fragen wir nochmal nach in Washington
bei Benjamin Daniel joiden willst also
noch mal wissen viele kritisieren ja
seine USA hatten die US-Demokraten keine
Alternative
naja ganz offenbar nicht und das zeigt
einmal mehr wie groß das
rekrutierungsproblem der Demokraten ist
viele hatten ja nach der Wahl 2020 ihre
Hoffnungen auf Kamera Harris gesetzt
dass sie eventuell 2024 selbst als
Kandidatin antreten kann aber sie ist in
den letzten Jahren doch sehr im
Hintergrund geblieben konnte bei keinem
Thema so richtig punkten und auch sonst
hat sich keine Kandidatin oder kein
Kandidat aufgetan also soll es jetzt
doch wieder Joe Biden richten er wird
nächstes Jahr 82 Jahre alt und ähm aber
trotz seines hohen Alters und seiner
schlechten Umfragewerte ist sein Kampf
alles andere als aussichtslos denn vor
allem der rechte Flügel der Republikaner
der führt seinen erbitterten Kulturkampf
immer weiter z.B bei dem Thema
Abtreibung Schulbildung Waffengesetze
und dieser extreme Kurs der geht
mittlerweile selbst vielen aus den
eigenen Reihen zu weit und im übrigen
errichtet sich auch oft gegen den
mehrheitswellen der Amerikanerinnen und
Amerikaner also ich glaube dass wir
daher uns wieder auf einen
nervenaufreibenden und offenen Wahlkampf
einstellen müssen danke wenn ihr mir
nach Washington
vier Jahre ist es her da war der jetzt
so brutal umkämpfte Sudan ein Land
voller Hoffnungen nach dem Sturz des als
korrupt und diktatorisch geltenden
Präsidenten al basira schien vieles
möglich Frieden eine echte Regierung
Demokratie alles vergessen seit zehn
Tagen kämpfen zwei Generäle um die Macht
im Land das darüber zu zerbrechen droht
viele Staaten haben mitten im Chaos ihre
Bürger außer Landes gebracht die vorerst
letzte deutsche evakuierungsmission ist
gerade im Gange Thomas Gonsior
endlich raus aus dem Sudan und erstmal
rein in eine A400M die Transportmaschine
nach Jordanien wie eine rettende Arche
voll mit Familien Kindern es hilft es
koordiniert die Bundeswehr der
Verteidigungsminister mit vorläufiger
Bilanz wir haben mit fünf
evakuierungsflüge durchgeführt wir sind
jetzt bei knapp 500 Menschen die
ausgeflogen worden sind davon etwa ein
Drittel gut ein Drittel deutsche
ansonsten viele europäische
Nationalitäten Flug wird voraussichtlich
heute Abend noch rausgehen dann war's
das erstmal danach sollen andere
Nationen dafür sorgen dass Ausländer den
Sudan verlassen können auch weitere
deutsche das hier ist in shibuti und es
ist der Moment in dem eine
niederländische Familie weiß wir sind in
Sicherheit
Arthur filmte seine abenteuerliche
Flucht mit seinen Kindern
per Bus ging es raus aus der Hauptstadt
cartoum
gespenstisch eine Geisterstadt sagt er
überall waren Checkpoints und Soldaten
und wir sahen das Kämpfe weitergingen
und dann der Flug auseinanders was ihm
sorge bereite sagt molinar sein seine
sudanesischen Freunde die lassen wir
zurück in einer schlimmen Situation und
ich glaube dass es noch schlimmer wird
denn für Sudanesen sind keine Flüge
vorgesehen bleibt nur der Landweg und
nur für den der Geld hat die meisten
aber müssen bleiben haben tagelang ihre
Häuser nicht verlassen aus Angst vor
Gewalt nun strömen viele zum Markt und
zum Arzt sorgen das Nötigste und
riskieren ihr Leben denn die Waffenruhe
ist brüchig und ob sie bis morgen Abend
hält das wissen sie nicht die Zivilisten
im Sudan
direkter Nachbar von Sudan ist Ägypten
von dort beobachtet lügbar die Situation
lügt bis morgen gilt offiziell die
Waffenruhe was passiert danach
die Hoffnung der vielen Menschen im
Sudan ist dass diese Waffenruhe auch
danach noch halten möge aber beide
Kriegs Generäle sowohl der Armeechef als
auch der Milizen Chef haben schon
angekündigt dass sie auf jeden Fall
einen Kampf bis zum Ende wollen daneben
gibt es aber hinter den Kulissen massive
diplomatische Bemühungen
US-Außenminister blinken hat heute
erklärt er stehen in engen Kontakt mit
vielen Verbündeten man versuche ein
Komitee zusammen
mit zivilkräften in Sudan um die beiden
generell an einen Verhandlungstisch zu
bringen wie weit das gedien ist weiß man
nicht heute gab es erst mal weiter
Gefechte aber weniger als in den letzten
Tagen rund um den Präsidentenpalast wir
haben es eben im Bild gesehen viele
Menschen in katumen haben die Stunde
genutzt um wenigstens nötiges
einzukaufen ein wenig Gemüse oder Brot
wenn es denn das noch gibt und andere
versuchen wahrscheinlich weiterhin eine
Flucht vorzubereiten auch wenn das sehr
teuer ist Benzin ist praktisch und
bezahlbar geworden also man muss sich
auf alle möglichen Szenarien einstellen
vielen Dank nach Kairo rückwalport
russland hat ein weiteres Mal gedroht
das getreideabkommen mit der Ukraine
nicht zu verlängern die so wichtige
Ausfuhr aus Odessa über das Schwarze
Meer die wäre dann ab Mitte Mai nicht
mehr möglich was das für Europa bedeutet
darüber beraten zur Stunde die
EU-Landwirtschaftsminister denn schon
jetzt exportiert die Ukraine große
Mengen Getreide auf dem Landweg die
Folge massiv sinkende Preise in
Osteuropa Polen die Slowakei Ungarn und
Bulgarien Schränken darum den
getreideimport ein anderen wie Rumänien
bieten sich neue Möglichkeiten aus
Konstanzer Britta Hilpert
eine entwicklungsturbo ist der Ukraine
Krieg für den rumänischen Hafen
Konstanzer neues Terminal neue Schienen
rund 25% des Getreides und der Ölsaaten
der Ukraine schlagen Sie hier um so
biorell panait es geht nach Westeuropa
und in afrikanische Länder
die Situation hat sich seit Kriegsbeginn
verbessert wir haben den Fluss des
ukrainischen Getreides besser
organisiert
doch viel wird auch teuer über Land
transportiert und oft auf nahen
EU-Märkten verkauft dagegen
protestierten manche Bauern einige
osteuropäische Länder verhängten sogar
Importverbote
Innenpolitik später immer auch eine
Rolle wie in Polen der Wahlkampf doch
nicht nur
jetzt welchen Schaden unsere Landwirte
erleiden welche Turbulenzen es gibt auf
den Märkten für Agrarprodukte langsam
versteht das auch die EU-Kommission
verplombt erlaubt Polen nun ukrainische
Einfuhren als Transit in andere Länder
doch der wichtigste exportweg bleibt der
aus Odessa die russische Drohung das
unabkommen dazu auslaufen zu lassen sei
gefährlich meinen Experten dann bedeutet
das dass ich die Versorgungslage auf dem
globalen Agrarmarkt über Nacht wieder
deutlich verschärft und das bedeutet im
Endeffekt steigende Preise und mehr
Hunger in Entwicklungsländern die Welt
braucht das Getreide die Ukraine die
Einnahmen daraus die EU ist unter Druck
neue exportwege zu ermöglichen
und darum die Frage zu Florian Neuheim
nach Brüssel wie will die EU die Kuh vom
Eis holen
man versucht erstmal mit einer typisch
Brüssel Herangehensweise nämlich etwas
Geld um die Wogen zu glätten die
EU-Kommission stellt hier 100 Millionen
Euro an Fördermitteln für Landwirte in
Osteuropa in Aussicht um eben dort den
Landwirten zu helfen denn man hat
einerseits großes Verständnis für die
Probleme die Sorgen der Landwirte dort
die jetzt eben volle Lage haben ihr
eigenes Getreide nicht mehr loswerden
aber andererseits ist das Unverständnis
auch die Verärgerung groß quer durch
Europa über diesen einseitig verhängten
den von vier aus der europäischen
Staaten viele Staaten viele Minister
haben das heute ja auch deutlich
kritisiert von Finnland bis Frankreich
wurde gesagt man könnte doch nicht
anders als groß von Solidarität mit der
Ukraine reden und dann andererseits das
Getreide aus der Ukraine blockieren das
zitatspiele Putin in die Hände aber
bisher haben sind diese vier aus der
europäischen Staaten nicht zufrieden mit
dem was Brüssel ihnen anbietet es ist am
Ende wohl eine Frage des Geldes und eine
Frage wann die Solidarität mit Ukraine
eben endet Florian vielen Dank für deine
Einschätzung nach Brüssel jetzt nach
Deutschland zu einer neuen Studie zur
Diskriminierung von Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund ein Ergebnis gut
jeder dritte berichtet von
Benachteiligungen oder Beleidigungen in
den vergangenen zwölf Monaten aber auch
das zeigt die Bertelsmann Untersuchung
Deutschland ist deutlich sensibler dafür
geworden was den Diskriminierung den
Menschen antut Christian Rufus berichtet
als hamado di Parma in Augsburg eine
Wohnung sucht nutzt ihm sein deutscher
Pass nicht viel das Apartment wäre eben
nur für deutsche frei sagt der Vermieter
und dann sagt er wie ist ihr Name noch
mal und ich sag mal Namen gesagt nee es
gab genügend Ausländer im Haus mehr
brauche ich nicht so eindeutig ist
Rassismus nicht immer welche Worte
verletzen können welche Taten ausgrenzen
die Jüngeren sagt die Parma entwickeln
mittlerweile ein besseres Gefühl mit
älteren Leuten unterhält es ist schon
oft so dass sie dafür noch nicht so den
Blick dafür haben und da ist noch nicht
so geschärft sind ich glaube es ist
einfach eher ähm ein Wandel ein
Wertewandel und ich habe auch das Gefühl
dass wenn man dann ins Gespräch kommt
darüber dass man dann nicht auf
Ablehnung stößt sondern auch auf
Interesse dieser Wertewandel schlägt
sich auch ein Ergebnis in einer
repräsentativen Bertelsmann Studie
wieder danach ist das Interesse am Thema
Gleichbehandlung in der
Gesamtbevölkerung deutlich gestiegen
jeder dritte mit Migration
ionsgeschichte spricht von Rassismus
Erfahrungen in den letzten 12 Monaten
dazu fordern vor allem die Jüngeren dass
anti-diskriminierungsgesetze verschärft
werden müssten politische Reformen
fordert deshalb auch die antike
diskriminierungsbeauftragte die
Regierung der letzten viele Jahre haben
das Thema Antidiskriminierung
verschlafen oder klein geredet manchmal
sogar ideologisch bekämpft so kommt es
dass wir in Deutschland immer noch eines
der schwächsten
Antidiskriminierungsgesetze in Europa
haben auch deshalb will sich die Parma
weiter einsetzen wie so viele die sich
ein gutes Miteinander wünschen
nach vielen Fragezeichen im Fall der
messeangriffe in einem Duisburger
Fitnessstudio hat sich die zuständige
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft geäußert die
Ermittler haben inzwischen Hinweise dass
es sich um einen islamistischen
Terrorakt gehandelt haben könnte auf dem
Handy des Festgenommenen Syrers fand
sich verdächtiges Material bei der
Attacke vor einer Woche waren vier
Menschen schwer verletzt worden der
Verdächtige 26-Jährige schweigt bislang
zu den Vorwürfen
einen islamistischen Anschlag sollen
auch zwei syrische Brüder geplant haben
ein 28-Jähriger Verdächtiger wurde in
Hamburg festgenommen er soll sich über
Online-Plattformen Chemikalien für den
Bombenbau besorgt haben offenbar wollte
er einen Sprengstoffgürtel für einen
Anschlag herstellen auch gegen seinen
24-Jährigen Bruder aus Kempten im Allgäu
wird ermittelt er steht im Verdacht der
Beihilfe
es war das Sonderangebot das fast ganz
Deutschland im vergangenen Sommer
elektrisierte das 9 euro-ticket gültig
für den nah und Regionalverkehr im
gesamten Land nach langem Tauziehen um
die Kosten geht jetzt der Nachfolge am 1
Mai an den Start rund 750.000 Menschen
haben sich das deutschland-ticket für 49
€ schon besorgt Svenja Domeyer der
Nachfolger des 9-euro-tickets von
verkehrsverbänden und Politik gefeiert
als tarifrevolution mit dem
deutschland-ticket Busse Straßenbahn und
Nahverkehrszüge Nutzen für 49 Euro
monatlich nur Fernzüge Kosten weiter
extra
nach einer ersten Prognose können wir
von 750.000 neuen abonnenteninnen und
Abonnenten sprechen bis jetzt das ist
erstmal eine gute Zahl bis zu 6
Millionen neue Abonnenten sollen in den
nächsten Monaten hinzukommen
prognostiziert der Branchenverband
gekauft werden kann das Ticket digital
über Apps oder direkt bei den
Verkehrsunternehmen wer aber eine
Chipkarte möchte der muss die bis zum 10
des Vormonats beantragen wir hatten
gerade im Vorfeld einiges an Ansturm
gehabt das war nicht ganz so stark wie
beim 9 € Ticket liegt natürlich auch
daran dass dieses teurer und es ist ein
Abonnement das heißt ich muss es
abschließen das ist komplizierter für
die Fahrgäste aber wir hatten einen
durchaus erkennbaren Ansturm gerade im
April auf das Ticket das Abo ist
monatlich kündbar und der Preis dürfte
vor allem für Pendler die den ÖPNV schon
jetzt regelmäßig nutzen von Vorteil sein
weitere Vergünstigung für einzelne
Gruppen wie Schüler Studierende oder
Senioren bleiben jedoch unterschiedlich
noch gibt es weiterhin Sonderregelungen
je nach Bundesland aber es ist eben doch
ein großer Schritt in Richtung Tarif
Einheit in Deutschland
Wermutstropfen um den ÖPNV langfristig
zu finanzieren da sind sich Experten
sicher wird auch das deutschland-ticket
schon in naher Zukunft wieder teurer
werden
auf der ganzen Welt hat das Publikum ihn
geliebt und bewundert harry Belafonte
einer der größten Musikstars seiner Zeit
ist mit 96 Jahren in New York verstorben
der Sohn eines Matrosen und einer
Hilfsarbeiterin begeisterte als Sänger
fernseh-entertainer und Schauspieler und
immer war er weit mehr als ein
gefeierter Bühnenstar ein mutiger
Kämpfer gegen Unterdrückung ein
populärer Aktivist für eine gerechtere
bessere Welt Christoph
[Musik]
du kleiner wenn man nicht ganz genau
hinhörte Arbeit und Ausbeutung so wenn
man es tat vor allem in dem einen Lied
Hafenarbeiter die Bananen verladen kurz
vor Schicht Ende aufgenommen 1956 alle
Welt wollte das Hören 31 Charts Wochen
lang aus bekannt wurde Weltstar mit ein
paar Tönen nur
ich habe immer nach leichten eingängigen
Songs gesucht die besten kamen alle aus
meiner Kindheit aus der Zeit bei meiner
Großmutter in Jamaika dabei hat der
kleine Junge aus New York anfangs einen
ganz anderen Traum der erste schwarze
Hamlet auf der Bühne will er werden
Talent ist da bringt dir mein
Schauspielstudium in einem guten
Jahrgang Tony Curtis und Marlon Brando
lernen in derselben Klasse
Carmen Soldat liebt arbeite Mädchen
beschert ihm 1954 den Leinwand
Durchbruch aber Calypso Entertainer
bellafonte kann eben alles und die Leute
hören ihn doch so gerne singen im Paket
dazu bekommen Sie immer den politisch
engagiert Mann
viele haben mich gefragt weil ich als
Künstler entschieden habe einen Aktivist
zu werden aber es war genau andersrum
ich war schon politisch aktiv als ich
Künstler wurde
gegen Rassentrennung für Bürgerrechte
gegen Apartheid für gesellschaftliche
Fairness für seine Ideale wird Harry
Belafonte kämpferisch ein hübscher
Zufall banana baut hatte der singende
Schauspieler damals eigentlich nur als
Lückenfüller aufgenommen doch im ewigen
Hit steckt fast der ganze bellafonte
drin ehrlich fröhlich einfühlsam und
nachdenklich
[Musik]
schade jetzt zur Fußball-Bundesliga
absolute Krisenstimmung bei den Bayern
das Gegenteil bei den Dortmundern diesen
bester Dinge Katja sie sind auch
vorsichtig einen Punkt Vorsprung haben
sie vor den Münchner allerdings stehen
auch noch fünf Spieltage aus der nächste
am Freitag gegen Bochum möglicherweise
ohne Stamm Stammspieler Nico
Schlotterbeck er hat
Oberschenkelprobleme es herrscht also
eingeschränkte Euphorie zumindest im
Verein während die BVB-Fans unverhohlen
von der ersten Meisterschaft seit elf
Jahren Träumen traten ihre Idole heute
betont ernst und fokussiert auf an der
eigenen Glanzvorstellung gegen Frankfurt
wollen Sie sich lieber nicht berauschen
angesichts unerklärlicher Punkt Verluste
in dieser Saison
bange sollte ihn vor dem Spiel bei den
abstiegsbedrohten Bochum Mann aber
ebenso wenig sein zumal ihre Titel
Konkurrenten aus Bayern dort leicht und
locker mit sieben zu null gewonnen
allerdings war das am dritten Spieltag
vergangenen August zur Zeit na also in
denen die Bayern noch voller
Selbstvertrauen waren so weit sind die
Dortmunder noch lange nicht kein Fehler
also weiterhin demütig zu bleiben
der Sportjournalist und Fernsehmoderator
Ernst Hubert die ist tot er verstarb
gestern im Alter von 96 Jahren Huberti
moderierte am 4 juni 1961 der erste
Sportschau und nicht nur die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der ARD trauern und trauern
um ein Urgestein der
Sportberichterstattung
so kannte und schätzte ihn sein Publikum
als Mister Sportschau mit
Fernsehauftritten und Reportagen
erreichte Ernst Huberti ein riesiges
Publikum bis zu 15 Millionen Zuschauer
sahen im Schnitt jeden Samstag die
Sportschau
guten Abend meine Damen und Herren
dieses Szene werden Sie mit Sicherheit
in unserer Sendung Wiedersehen Tor ja
oder nein bei der Weltmeisterschaft 1970
kommentierte er das sogenannte
Jahrhundertspiel zwischen Deutschland
und Italien und sprach beim deutschen
Ausgleich seine unvergessenen Reporter
Worte
auch Bundesligisten wie Dortmund und
Bayern München würdigten Huberti als
Vorbild im deutschen Sportjournalismus
betonten seine außergewöhnliche
Souveränität und Sachlichkeit das war's
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
ohne Zweifel eine Legende danke dir
Katja ausgerechnet heute Nacht noch mal
Frost 1 leiten gleich von Katja
horneffer das heute journal mit
Christian Sievers gibt zum 21:45 Uhr
danke schön fürs zuschauen und noch
einen schönen Abend für Sie
[Musik]
guten Abend Ende April da kann es ja
schon mal sommerlich warm sein aber
aktuell stehen die Zeichen auf Spätfrost
und das liegt an der Kombination
zwischen diesem Tief
übersichtskandinavien und dem Hoch bei
Schottland wenn es dann nachts aufklagt
dann wird das eisig kalt dann rot Luft
Frost Frost in 2 m Höhe von -4 bis -1
Grad Bodenfrost aber gibt es ganz
verbreitet in Deutschland ihre
empfindlichen Pflanzen sollten Sie also
bitte schützen denn häufig ist die Nacht
klar hin und wieder bildet sich auch
etwas Nebel an der Nordsee fällt Regen
und etwas Regen fällt auch ganz im Süden
an den Alpen kann auch Schnee dabei sein
weitere Schauer ziehen morgen von der
Nordseeküste die Elbe entlang weiter
Richtung Uckermark bei einem West
Nordwestwind Freunde hier sieht's auf
Rügen außen auch ein Ostfriesland und
auch mit dem Mittelgebirgen sehen sie
häufiger mal die Sonne genauso wie in
Süddeutschland nur zwischen den
Berchtesgadener Land und dem Allgäu sind
die Wolken dichter und bringen auch noch
die Temperaturen liegen morgen zwischen
8°c
also deutlich milder mit bis zu 19 Grad
am Freitag kommt von Westen der nächste
Regen mit Gewittern heran und der
Samstag wird dann im Nordosten ganz
freundlich guten Abend